what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and Sony just teased something pretty
big but then deleted it after they
released the video and what they teased
is seemingly a Venom Multiverse of some
sorts we have venom 3 coming out with
Tom Hardy relatively soon it's supposed
to release next year July 12th of 2024
and Tom Hardy has been teasing a
Spider-Man crossover for Venom 3 and he
has teased this many times and true Tom
Hardy fashion he typically posts a
picture to Instagram of Venom and
Spider-Man and then deletes it but of
course people grab the photos before it
could be put down people have the
notifications turned on for him so as
soon as he post that photo they take the
screenshot and we all see it and he
knows that people are going to do this
he does this on purpose and it looks
like now Sony might have done the same
thing the other day Sony Pictures UK
posted a tick tock and this video was of
Tom Hardy's Venom interacting with with
Topher Grace's Venom from Spider-Man 3
and it caught our attention at first
wondering is this going to be some type
of plot for Venom 3 is the Multiverse
actually going to be a part of Venom 3.
we know Sony has been diving deep into
the Multiverse with Spider-Man across
the spider-verse into the spider-verse
and then upcoming beyond the
spider-verse and across the spider-verse
did confirm that live action and
animated worlds can intertwine they can
mix together they can cross over so are
we getting a Multiverse in the
Spider-Man villain universe that Sony
Pictures has established and more
importantly if we are are we getting to
for Grace's Venom in venom 3 and are we
getting a Spider-Man in venom 3 because
again Tom Hardy has teased this but if
they're teasing Topher Grace does that
mean Toby Maguire Spider-Man could
actually come and be the Cameo
Spider-Man in venom 3. you also have to
keep in mind that Tom Hardy's venom has
already Multiverse traveled he doesn't
exactly realize it right now he's got
kind of a hint when he went to the MCU
he was talking to the bartender he
learned about the Avengers he learned
about Spider-Man he clearly realized
that something was up he may not know
that it's the Multiverse when he was in
a different universe but he ended up
going back because Sony and Marvel
Studios teased Us big time they put
Venom Tom Hardy's Venom in the MCU and
then they took him back leaving a piece
of the Symbiote behind telling us
unfortunately that it looks like Tom
Hardy's Venom is not going to be the
main Venom of the MCU and that's
disappointing but at the same time now
the MCU can do the comic accurate origin
story of Venom where he attaches to
Peter Parker first Peter Parker rejects
him he goes to Eddie Brock and then from
there Venom hates Peter Parker and
Spider-Man for those wanting that comic
accurate story of Venom and Spider-Man
we're gonna get that in the MCU
eventually probably in secret Wars which
of course this also does open it up for
Tom Hardy's Venom to appear in Avengers
Secret Wars Sony and Marvel Studios are
clearly playing nice with each other the
post-credits scene for Venom 2 had Venom
in the MCU and the post-credits scene
for Spider-Man no way home also had
Venom in the MCU clearly they're
cooperating with each other but since
Venom went to the MCU and came back it
means one he has already Multiverse
traveled two he knows about Spider-Man
and three it probably means a Spider-Man
is going to show up in venom 3 now the
only question is which Spider-Man this
tease by Sony gets us thinking that
perhaps Toby Maguire Spider-Man is going
to be returning if Topher Grace's Venom
is being teased here for a possible
crossover well that's the world we
assume that Toby Maguire Spider-Man is
in but Sony does also have plans to
essentially do a big spider-verse in
live action form Sony has already
confirmed that Miles Morales is going to
be getting his own movie they have
basically confirmed the live-action
spider-verse is coming and we've already
gotten it really we got it in Spider-Man
no way home and again Spider-Man across
the spider-verse did confirm that the
live-action universes can cross over
with the animated universes and we've
been hearing rumors that Sony is setting
up a Spider-Man Universe to have a
spider gedden storyline basically
Spider-Man no way home times about 20.
maybe more it's a huge event where all
the Spider-Man crossover even Spider-Man
from Spider-Man PS4 goes into the comics
it's basically Spider-Man across the
spider verse in the hub that we saw but
from what we've heard Sony is building
up to that that is kind of their end
game that is their secret Wars that they
want to build up to with their own
Universe not kind of in collaboration
with Marvel Studios but on their own and
in order to do that they have to start
introducing Spider-Man in this
Spider-Man villain universe and we kind
of felt hints of Spider-Man in the Crave
in the hunter trailer that we got so
maybe we're going to start to feel
Spider-Man a little bit more in all of
these movies that are coming from Sony
but again Tom Hardy has been teasing
Spider-Man for a very long time in the
post-credits scene for Venom 2 clearly
shows us that Venom and Eddie Brock now
know who Spider-Man is and Eddie even
talked about finding him so we assume in
venom 3 3. Eddie and Venom aren't going
to forget that they essentially jumped
universes and it sounds like Venom with
his Hive knowledge probably knows a
little bit about the Multiverse as well
and could probably tell Eddie hey we
just jumped between universes we're back
now but we were at a different one
before and we know that Eddie's gonna
want to find Spider-Man in his own
universe and he's going to seek answers
and what's interesting is we assumed for
a bit that Andrew Garfield Spider-Man
was going to be the Spider-Man in venom
3 and that still is very much a
possibility we assume this because of
the line that was said in Spider-Man no
way home where Andrew Garfield's
Spider-Man said that he wants to fight
an alien he's the only Spider-Man that
hadn't fought one Toby Maguire's of
course fought Topher Grace's Venom in
Spider-Man 3 and as far as aliens are
concerned Tom Holland Spider-Man of
course bought Thanos but both Andrew
Garfield and Toby Maguire said that they
were both open to returning again to
play Spider-Man and right after
Spider-Man no way home insiders started
talking and started stating that Andrew
Garfield was not done that Toby Maguire
was not done and Sony had plans for them
well perhaps Sony's plans was for Venom
specifically Venom 3 since we already
know Sony clearly has plans for
Spider-Man and it looks like Venom is
now going to be a part of the Multiverse
now this may be Sony's Multiverse again
maybe ultimately leading up to a spider
get in storyline or it could also be a
part of the mcu's Multiverse the old Fox
X-Men are going to be appearing in
Deadpool 3 and Avengers Secret Wars and
sent Sony and Marvel Studios are playing
nice with each other right now it would
make sense to possibly have Tom Hardy's
Venom show up in Avengers Secret Wars as
well as Topher Grace's Venom that could
be something that they're hinting at
here or possibly for Deadpool 3 because
we know that Deadpool 3 is going to have
a ton of different cameos in it as they
explore the Multiverse but what is this
tease from Sony mean for Venom 3 because
it's clearly a Venom tease his Topher
Grace's Venom going to be appearing in
venom 3 is there a possibility that
Eddie and Venom when they went to the
CEO and came back somehow ended up and
Toby Maguire and Topher Grace's
Spider-Man and Venom Universe the Sam
raymie universe will call it could that
be a possibility yes absolutely and
could that be what Sony is planning it
is absolutely possible that it could be
given how they've had massive success
with Spider-Man no way home with
Spider-Man into the spider-verse across
the spider-verse and they're planned
beyond the spider-verse and planned
Miles Morales Solo movie they've clearly
seen how big of a success the Multiverse
with Spider-Man can be for them and
probably are trying to incorporate that
in their main story and if all the
rumors that we've heard are true then
yes they are going to incorporate the
spider-verse in their main Spider-Man
villain universe and that could be what
we see in venom 3. now another option is
that universes are kind of starting to
collide maybe they won't call them
incursions because that's what Marvel
Studios is using right now but just like
in Spider-Man no way home how villains
were kind of entering the main MCU
universe that could would have an effect
on the Sony spider-verse so maybe they
do go back to their original universe
but somehow Topher Grace's venom has
crossed over into their Universe after
all Tom Hardy's Venom says you ever come
in here again we will find you now this
is reused footage from Venom one but
perhaps they are talking about his
Universe if you ever come in here again
if you ever come in my universe again
we'll eat you we'll kill you it may
sound crazy but the great thing is
literally anything is possible with the
Multiverse it really does open up a lot
of potential stories and I for one would
absolutely love to see Topher Grace's
Venom return if even for a brief cameo
in a new Venom movie some insiders did
report on this some time ago it probably
was over a year ago but it was reported
that he would be reprising his role for
a cameo now we kind of thought it might
have been the MCU but it could be the
Sony spider-verse and I think it would
be cool to see Venom variants because
that's something we haven't seen yet we
have seen Spider-Man variants but not
Venom but go ahead and let us know your
thoughts about this in the comments down
below why did Sony post this and then
delete it are they hinting at something
and if they are would you like to see
Topher Grace's Venom show up in venom
three let us know your thoughts about
this in the comments down below and if
you comment and subscribe to the channel
you are automatically entered in our
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items the winner gets to pick
one item and we pick a winner at the end
of each month you can find us on
Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching wolf